thank you
so let's just jump right into it if you
could uh
as a note in the introduction a
congressman a governor and vice
president
can you talk about the relative prompts
and cons of positives the negatives of
those various roles further
team how much time do we have let's
focus on the positive well first first
let me just thank fairness Society thank
you so much for the warm welcome today
thank you for that warm overly generous
introduction more importantly I want to
thank the men and women of the
Federalist Society
for the stand that UK as officers of the
Court every day for the Constitution of
the United States of America God bless
you all
and I I must say you know for me to have
been able to serve the Congress of the
United States and serve as governor of
Indiana and the great privilege for
serving as your vice president has an
incredible journey for me and one that I
had the privilege to capture in my
recent Memoir
um entitled so healthy God which you
know
I don't know if I mentioned that I wrote
a book recently
I'm contractually obligated prevention
activities
but for me I I really feel like a guy
that had the opportunity to
to take insurance through
the
the form of government that our Founders
contemplated
to be part of the legislative branch to
be in the law banking process was a
great great privilege for me I serve
both in a Republican majorities and
minorities and
actually was part of winning back in the
jewelry in 2010 I served under a
president of my own party and a
president of the other party and and
learning the Dynamics of the House of
Representatives but then my my wife took
me to returning to Indiana where I
served as Governor there
really came to appreciate the dynamic
nature of the Federalist system
that our Founders and trying you know to
understand the Constitution of the
United States
many many people will point to the 10th
Amendment that says that the power is
not delegated to the federal government
or reserve the states and to the people
but in many ways I feel that the 10th
Amendment is just an explanation mark
at the end of of a document that up to
that point was all about limited
government
uh and it was it was as though if you
had missed the point we want to say it
one more time
in this Bill of Rights that this is a
system I love what Ronald Reagan said in
his first inaugural address and it's
important to remember that the state's
created the Federal Government the
federal government didn't create the
states and I must tell you the
opportunity to have gone home
and been a part of one of those
Laboratories of innovation
uh and to see what we were able to do
for an education department Health Care
reform a broad range of areas really
gave me a great sense of Vitality of our
system and and when I became vice
president I tried to carry that same
experience from from both the Congress
in the United States and as Governor
into into our Administration I'm very
proud that our Administration was able
to move legislation and Advance Freedom
we move we move legislation that that
pulled back on the regulatory State much
focus of uh of this conference today we
unleashed American Energy we secured our
border but um
great flexibility to the states
particularly when it came to what was
known as waivers given States the
capacity to try new ideas particularly
when it came to Medicaid much of that's
been undone by the by Administration
with very little public notice in the
media but it's a curve that the
flexibility that we have given a state
starting to confess Administration has
been pulled back but all along the way I
just feel like for me
each each element of our government has
their own
uh and it has their own role but but to
have been able to serve
in a legislative branch in the executive
branch International level but also to
serve as the chief executive of the
state just remind me of how Dynamic our
system is and how the the framework of
our foundation is very outset
is still vital and important it holds
the keys
to a balance American future
I mentioned in my introduction this is
the Federalist society's 11th they take
your branch review conference where we
try to take a close-up examination of
the administrative so I also mentioned
your initiative uh for a smaller and
more effective government that are
unconsciously a very quick joke uh
involves two people who worked in an
agency and one asked the second one it's
like how many people work in your agency
and the other one said the second one
said in the first one about half
[Laughter]
and I've been involved in combinations
were very very hard but I'm wondering if
I'm those three purchasing that if you
want to say a little bit more about the
administration conversating
you probably were involved into Ministry
of actors as the governor you were the
recipient of federal funds meeting with
his unfamil strings that came from
agencies and then the vice president you
had enrolled overseeing all of it
um you want to take down any deeper on
the District of State itself and then
return to your book
well I think
restraining and reclaiming
the legislative prerogatives of the
legislative branch from the
administrative state
should be one of the most important
objectives of the next Republican
Administration
when you need no further than a recent
case they can reflect on one that our
foundation became involved in where the
FDA 20 years ago bypassed their own
rules and the requirements of the law to
improve medical Crystal and then for uh
for 20 years
with many women around the country
hundreds and hundreds of documented
cases in the first few years of women
suffering severe consequences uh nearly
a dozen documented deaths in the face of
medical personnel then the FDA under the
Obama Administration
cease collecting data on negative Health
outcomes apart from fatalities and and I
I just really believe this is number one
I'm a pro-life I don't apologize for it
I I couldn't be more proud to have been
a small part of the administration that
appointed three of the justices that
sent Roe versus Wade to the asking of
History where it belongs and gives a new
beginning for life
but in this instance this to me is as
much about
the cause of The Unborn and the cause of
protecting women but it's also it's also
about reigning in an administrative
setting
I mean 20 years ago as a mark weed at
Great Federalist Society
American Freedom wrote it is the biggest
brief in that case
literally the FDA used an emergency
Provisions that were enacted to
facilitate addressing the HIV crisis
25 years ago to approve Chris stuff it
was a
demonstrably political movement approved
by politics and not by science and
there's just one example the legions of
examples where the administrative States
overreached and essentially usurped the
legislative Authority it's one of the
reasons why I think one of the most
important bills uh to be passed by the
Congress was actually written by a
predecessor of mine
who was uh remember served one of the
co-founders of federal society that
former Congressman David McIntosh show
what came be noticed the Congressional
review Act
uh in the late 1990s
we would use it a number of times during
the Republic majority of undo things
everything's famous
ergonomic rules regarding chairs that
were about to cost businesses hundreds
of millions of dollars we were able to
rescind that and it was very recently
that President Biden used his first veto
pen
to The veto of a a congressional review
act effort to undo the imposition of
environmental social governance
Provisions in investing in America it's
extraordinary that the president of the
United States literally put their
radical climate liberal agenda ahead of
pensioners and hard-working Americans
interests with that veto ban and I I
would submit to you that I believe that
these the efforts by Republicans and
what became a bipartisan bill in the
United States Senate Venezuelan
presidency that's a sadly veto but this
is a this is a battle that to me it's
one of the reasons I love
attorneys in the Federalist Society
because everything begins with
Constitution
um and uh I mean under our formal
government
uh
the first job that I had in public life
is where the law is getting made
all right and do you all understand the
presidents of the Chevron and other
major precedents that gave excessive
latitude was one of the reasons why when
I was participating in the interview for
our first opening on Supreme Court of
the United States I was in Africa and I
will tell you
we had no greater champion of reigning
in the administrative State uh the
Justice Neil Gorsuch and I'm proud to
have seen him add a supreme court of the
United States
and it's one of the great challenges of
our time in Civilization
can you tell us a little bit about why
you chose that as the title foreign
copies for us we're delighted too and
thank you for mentioning my book I don't
know if I mentioned
[Music]
uh
the title of the book
was really inspired in two ways
first while this is the story of our
lives in so many ways it's
it's really a story of God's
faithfulness of my life
if you read the pages of the spoke it
will you'll find the most important
decision I ever made was when I put my
faith in Jesus Christ
as my word savior
[Applause]
changed my life forever in 1978 and I
couldn't write my story without
reflecting on God's grace
in my life the time that I met the girl
in my dreams and
we got to take a shot of politics our
little family came along
but all along the way really for me at
the title
literally the title of the book is so
help me God bless three words of thank
you Jesus
so I support the inspiration
the other inspiration report really came
from the oath of office that I had the
privilege of taking
times
the history reports that when President
George Washington took the first dose of
offices first person in the United
States
four words
so I'll be gone and history and
tradition has continued that throughout
the years not just for presidents but
for members of Congress or governors
I'm proud to say that my son Michael is
the captain of the United States Marine
Corps my my son-in-law Henry is a
lieutenant in the United States Navy
they're both fighter pilots and they
both took the same open Office that I
took and and
for me it's it's always been since my
youth when I first I first began to
study the constitution in the high in
in a high school speech contest
and it as I write in the book it began
for me a lifelong love affair
with a Constitution which is the
greatest Charter of human freedom and
history of the world
the Constitution of the United States
and uh and all throughout my career I've
sought to to formulate and articulated
political philosophy that's ultimately
around the Constitution and throughout
my years of service through some
difficult days at the end of our
Administration I tried to
that I made
because I believe it was an oath that
that I took but pledge not just to the
American people but
but to almighty God and so the
inspiration of this focused on God's
faithfulness but also my my effort
throughout my life
to live out my oath to the Constitution
of the United States
and always do that with God
you might already have answered this
question
question what do you want people to take
away from the smoke essay
well I I hope that they they take away
from this book
a great sense of Pride about this
country
I mean even through the most difficult
days of my public service
our institutions help
our constitution now
as I said at the end of the book one of
the
the difficult part for me is seeing much
of the progress that we made that I
fought forward by years in Congress as
governor and as vice president see much
of the progress that we've made done by
Administration in less than two and a
half years
it is extraordinary to think of whether
it be the disastrous control from
Afghanistan whether it be the war on
energy whether it be undoing our
policies to the secured the Border
whether it be the gusher of needless
federal spending that's that's ignited
the worst inflation in 40 years it's a
time that it's easy for Americans
not to be concerned about the future but
as I as I say at the end of the book
I hope when people read the pages of
this book about a small town guy they
got to live with a dream
serve the psychiatrist's office in the
land that uh
that the challenge that we simply have
is we just got to have government as
good as our people again
we've got to have government that's just
as committed as
as the American people are our highest
ideals
and I believe we will and we will
someday soon
so how was God
let me ask you what might be a personal
a person in question but in the book
fantastic last one was pretty personal
this might go even deeper but families a
big part of this book particularly your
father
and wondering about the impact he had in
your life and would you think it's more
than a typical Father and Son
relationship and some part of that
question is a lot of people they write a
book they've got so many in mind they're
writing that too so on
um they're writing it for someone uh say
more about that if you could
well I love the second question because
I really know what's ever asked to do
that
you'd be surprised how many interviews
we'll do a lot of book that you're right
that are conducted by people that did
read the book
you know I really did I actually was
thinking of my grandkids
when I was writing the book
Karen and I became grandparents for the
first time
three times over the last two years
and that's what we call in our family a
good start
and all the blessings I've had in my
life the Privileges I've had serve our
country who would have imagined that I
would also the grandfather of the three
most beautiful little girls ever before
in the history of the world
um but I was I was writing it for uh for
Avery and Elena and Heather Rose I
really was
you know none of us are promised someone
and uh I wanted them to understand the
story
and our family story
is as you graciously point out someone
said to me when I was turning in a
manuscripts in this book they said you
know we think your dad is the secret
star of this book
loved
my dad left us in 1988
58 years old I wasn't even out of my 20s
yeah
who's the best man I ever met
combat veteran in the Korean War he came
home and married his first generation
irish-american redhead who's 90 years
young to the city
can't keep up with my mom
if I work down to a small town in
Indiana to a couple of big city kids
they really lived the American dream
as you said I like to say my dad build
everything that matters
a family of business a good name if you
did he did but he raised me and my three
brothers and two sisters
you know with just some core values my
dad wasn't very political at all
I'll tell people my dad was a
businessman just
nominally Republican right but a patriot
he loved this country believed in
America
but honestly he had no use for
politicians or lawyers
so you can imagine I was a great source
of pride
but I must tell you that uh
when he when he left us suddenly a hard
time
at age 58 he said the worst day of my
life
but he continues to be one of the
greatest influences in my life to this
day
and uh writing the book having a chance
to tell not just my story but to tell
Karen my story to tell my dad's story
tell the story of my grandfather who
stepped off on a boat on the Ellis
Island in 1923.
I mean think about that
I mean the the Richard Michael Cauley
you know
sets off on Ellis Island signs itself in
goes to Chicago Illinois drives us for
40 years and his grandson and Nancy
Michael Richard Pence
goes on to be Vice President of the
United States
is this a great country or well
I love your question about who I wrote
it for because I've never answered
another question till today
wrote about my granddaughters but uh
thanks for asking about my dad he's uh I
hope people are as inspired by his
examples
it's an extraordinary story and thank
you for sharing it um we're technically
at the time to add two more questions
I'm going to get to if we
first is there a backstory and can you
share about how you came to be
president Trump's running mate in 20
20. that's a bad word living question
and then I'm all finished with a I'm a
former question
well I remember reporters used to ask me
during the campaign in the 2016 and he
said what's the most surprising thing
about
your campaign
you know for vice president and I said
you mean other than the fact that I'm in
it
I remember when we got the call that uh
from a friend or a friend who said
someone a friend of mine was wondering
if you might want to be two
as a possible vice presidential thing I
was
taken aback
and full disclosure I had supported
another candidate in the Indiana primary
in 2016 and In fairness
Ted Cruz won all Three Counties on
campaign
and Donald Trump won the other 89.
no I didn't think I was on the call list
but when we got the call and uh
it was very interesting to me I
Karen and I immediately took the Magnum
prayer which is where we always try and
go first
and
I I contacted the spiritual friend and I
said
I said well in order to answer the
question I need to know a couple of
things I need to know them better
because we didn't know their family
whatever we do we do as a family
and uh and I said secondly I need to
know what the job description is
right I mean I really enjoy being a
governor and knew I could do a scholar
but
there's only one person that writes a
job description for vice president
four years right
and so I said you know we need to spend
some time with them that's not realistic
this is literally uh
you know
just before the Fourth of July with the
Republican National Convention coming
out in a matter of weeks I said I'm sure
it won't be possible they called me back
a day later and said well actually
um I said please tell them I don't be
offended by my answer I just this is
this an honest answer from my heart and
they called back the next day and said
well not only was it not offended he
loved your answer
and he wanted to invite you to
Bedminster bring your family their
family is going to be there this weekend
we want to spend a whole weekend with
you and spend time and talk about all
this which
we did we traveled to bed then sir and
arrived there on Friday evening and
that's the better part of the week and
talking talking through
uh not just his ideas about the role of
Vice President
which could be summed up in one word as
I wrote in my book
he said active
I said active and he said he said uh
yeah I mean you were a congressman I
wanted to be actually in Congress so she
acted around the country I wanted to be
active around the world here on foreign
be active
and I have to tell you after four years
as your vice president Trump has
Administration that's what we call a
promise made promise cat
it was active
but but I also I felt uh
you know there was Karen and I both felt
a great
ease with their families which surprises
a lot of people some people some people
think we're a little bit different
um
but honestly
honestly we had a we had an awesome
media report and I I had a sense that uh
that we could help
I had a sense of his uh his commitment
to an agenda less taxes and uh more for
you and conservatives on our courts with
an advanced publication on the list
of exclusively Federalist Society
potential nominees
we have to do a strong National Defense
you know with the uh with military and
Armenia family and so
I forget the night the phone rang it
would be about a week after we came home
and they visited Indiana
I got the heads up that you're going to
get a call tonight
we thought it was going to be an
invitation trying to take it
and I was standing in my study at the
governor's residence
my wife was at my side a few of our ears
were there farmer a I picked it up
and I heard that familiar voice said
Michael
it's going to be great
and then he went into it he said you
know look we're going to turn this
country around and when I don't know if
you go south I go well we're gonna have
to work with him to go out he talked for
like seven minutes straight never said a
word and I said
well if there's a question in there the
answer is yes
[Applause]
they said oh no no yeah right now I want
you to do that
great memories great experiences an
incredible sense of privilege but uh one
that we never saw
that's great well final question here
this one's going to take us back in time
and also have a forward-looking aspect
it's again from the book uh so help me
God uh and then you describe a meeting
that took place at the Capitol Police
Chief's office on 911 and you make the
observation that there were no
Republicans no Democrats there's feeling
of unity and it really did
uh pervade the country for for months
maybe years afterwards
uh that seems a good loss it seems like
ancient history at this point in time I
wonder if you've had thoughts about
whether we can get back to that sort of
feeling even as we celebrate differences
is it possible to reclaim that uh
without a national disaster
well the science was yeah
we just gotta have a government as good
as our people
and look the American people
are the most idealistic generous
compassion
respectful people in the first year
I traveled all across this country big
cities and small towns
I tell people sometimes with all due
respect to those who work in Washington
you know you get 15 miles out of
Washington DC the people in this country
actually get along pretty well
I think our politics is more divided
than ever before
I don't mean to diminished that
but I'm not convincing American people
who are survived as a politics
and I think if we will if we'll raise up
leadership that will express our highest
ideals
I think the American people will rally
to our cause I saw it not just on i-11
When the Smoke was still building from
the Pentagon
Ground Zero from the field outside
Jacksonville Pennsylvania
but frankly I saw in the immediate days
at the onset of the Covenant
traveling to Capitol Hill and a
partisanship was gone
for a while
people were interested before we we you
know at the beginning of those and
sometimes I've heard people write about
real Combat and talk about the father of
the war
some of the veterans in the room will
understand that better than I am the
world
but it's this notion of
not really knowing what's happening
around you I can tell you from the time
late February that I was tasked to lead
the White House buyers task force it was
a fall we we didn't know what we didn't
know we didn't know how dangerous it was
we didn't know how
contagious it was we didn't know who the
longest were
and in a very rare sense I sense a
spirit in those early weeks of of
genuine National Unity
and I will tell you there's a chapter in
the book entitled
only in America
because while there are lessons to be
learned from our experience with code
particularly those surrounding personal
freedom and how I strongly oppose the by
administration's Mandate of vaccines and
wish the Supreme Court would have not
done all the mandates
thank you
I do believe that what the American
people accomplish
ing that's a great tribute to a free
Society
I'll tell you a quick anecdote of that
time
and that is the
once things kind of began to settle a
little bit about three weeks after
we started reading task force some of
the criticism began from Capitol Hill
from some democrat orders they were
asking why we weren't using what's
called a defense production Act
which allows the government to order
private businesses to create certain
products in time a National Emergency
right
and the president had begun to attend
the Press briefings and he got a
question about it
why aren't you using the defense
production Act and the president
basically brought some times that we're
looking at it and let me get back with
you tomorrow on that
and if we're walking down the hall to
the Oval Office and he punched me in the
side of the arm and said why are we used
to defense production
and I looked at him as I wrote in my
book I looked at him and said because
nobody said no
and he stopped that destruction and said
what
and I said no business of any size in
America that we have called to do
anything has said no
everyone has said yes and nobody has
ever asked something to get paid for
I mean we we had
we had Automotive companies that all the
sudden open up lines to create
ventilators because we were facing a
dramatic ventilator shortage in America
we had thousands of people that died in
Italy because the lack of ventilated
equipment
and Automotive companies drop whatever
they were doing and it went to work we
had we had
we had a apparel company suddenly
starting to manufacture gallons and
basks and and gloves for healthcare
workers we we saw the way that American
industry set up it was attributed
it was attribute to free enterprise and
a free society and
uh and also a tribute to our national
Unity I just I really do believe that
there is
today has always been more than the
United States in this country that could
ever divide us
we just have to have leadership
that will express our values in
principled way
but Express them in a way that allows
for the discovery
of genuine Colin Brown
people that know me know I'm a
conservative but I'm not a bad vote
about it right and I don't believe in
compromising principle but I do believe
as the late Russell Kirk wrote that
politics is the art of the possible
and when you look about this mountain
range of debt facing those
granddaughters in line
it could literally go from 30 trillion
dollars to 150 trillion dollars
before they get out of college when you
look at the challenges facing Us in the
lighter world today
you look at a crisis at our order you
look at our economy look at the
challenges facing the family and parents
in America today
I believe that we as conservatives hold
the keys we hold the solutions
for America but but uh but our challenge
is to express those in a way that allows
us to move our nation forward and I I
believe we can
and I believe we will
well that's an optimistic note to end on
Mr Vice President you've been very
generous with your time and your
thoughts and sharing your thoughts uh I
can't thank you enough this has been
brilliant thank you for your time and to
the audience please join me in thanking
thank you all very much Society
foreign